[Musique]
anrig romana bonjour bonjour monsieur
niveau oui bonjour les auditeurs de
martinique 1ère et particulièrement les
dionysiennes et les denaisiens vous avez
66 ans maire depuis 2014 vous allez
mener la liste en 2020 asie sont pour le
devenir de fort st denis henry romana
qu'est ce qui vous motive
écoutez monsieur livre oui je vais te
simple vous savez je suis en phase de
clôture de mandature nous avons un bilan
qui est positif nous avons des retours
de la population de l'hygiène qui ne lui
demande de poursuivre avec mes
colistiers nous avons décidé de faire un
deuxième mandat pourquoi parce que vous
savez six ans échos et quand vous avez
une petite mairie que vous n'avez pas
disons de vrais services
c'est pas évident disons de prendre un
dossier de la mener à la réalisation
et pourtant nous avons fait beaucoup
depuis notre arrivée nous n'avons pas
chômé et je pense que nous avons
beaucoup de satisfactions avec le
travail réalisé pour un milieu améliorer
quelques coupes les conditions de vie
des derniers nés des dionysiens en 2017
il y a eu une élection partielle pour
compléter votre liste suite à des
démissions sept conseillers qui ont
démissionné
comment vous avez mieux choisie
aujourd'hui vos colistiers comment vous
voyez cela aujourd'hui
d'un côté moi je pense que l'équipe
actuelle est très soudée nous
travaillons de pair nous faisons un
travail en commun et aucun soucis de
fonctionnement les choses se passent au
mieux du monde
on dit que là que la commune est divisée
justement suite à
à ce départ la en 2017 et à ces
élections partielles en 10017 non la
commune n'est pas si divisé que cela
ceux qui sont partis on se rend compte
on en discute
des fois ils portent leur contribution
sur le plan politique je n'ai aucune
animosité envers quiconque la thur au
contraire je travaille même avec des
élus qui sont partis pour des motifs
divers très divers que je ne peux pas
développer ici mais je pense que j'ai
aucun aucun problème avec ceux qui ont
laissé le bateau très bien au niveau
manager toujours bpm vous savez monsieur
les bruits ce qui est déterminant c'est
pas l'appartenance à un parti un parti
c'est de répondre au mieux aux attentes
de la population vous savez nous sommes
dans une dans une espèce de stratégie
disons de jeudi et même de de
rassemblement et puis je fais plus géant
groupe huk est tout-à-fait hétéroclite
ma question était simple est ce que vous
êtes toujours ppm va écouter ya
longtemps que je ne participe plus aux
réunions du ppm je vais pas débattre ici
moi j'ai bien compris vous n'êtes plus
payé
voilà alors quelles sont les grandes
lignes de votre programme
les grands axes de bons progrès dans mon
programme je dirais que deux ans premier
temps j'ai déjà c'est de la satisfaction
pour le travail le travail réalisé et là
aussi je remercie mes colis ce que les
colistiers également les agents
municipaux qui ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied campus avant un bilan
aussi positif
nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec les
agriculteurs par exemple nous avons un
plan de développement économique rural
que nous sommes cela en phase finale et
qui est bientôt cela va commencer avec
un spécialiste de la bio avec
l'association la sauter et celui que
vous parle aussi temps en temps bon
participe aussi au labourage la sauter
avec cette association
je suis quelqu'un de la ruralité profond
de mon père était agriculteur ma mère
c'est pour cela que j'ai senti que je
dois remettre ça à la commune de fond
saint denis qui m'a donné le jour
pour moi c'est un sacrifice parce que
vous savez le boulot de maire c'est
quelque chose qui est très exigeant
ça demande aussi de là beaucoup de 2,2
je dirais même de charisme et aussi de
la disponibilité vous savez un maire
d'une commune rurale celle du 24 heures
sur 24
à deux heures du matin vous appelle vous
celui sur le livre vous partez et vous
allez dix fois mais dans la nature
rui pu récupérer quelqu'un qui quittait
porter perdu de 10 secondes à peine
autre axe autres axes de votre programme
le désenclavement de la commune
absolument le désenclavement que nous
travaillons actuellement avec la ctm là
le désenclavement de certains ouvrages
hydrauliques qui ne permet pas aux
véhicules d'entrée yab aisément au bout
des fonds se donner des encadrements
aussi concernant locaux léontine
pourquoi ne pas un jour relié le monde
rouge à france 2 ni et puis j'arrive et
les enclavement de gênes
concernant le quartier d'horizon qui
était prévu dans notre programme qu'on a
pas oublier qu'on est toujours attelé à
penser à le réaliser
merci monsieur romana je vous en prie
monsieur livory